we started with the golden well interval
right this guy over here we used it to
create if you make a square out of this
rectangle out of this you get the golden
rectangle if you nest within themselves
a whole bunch of golden rectangles right
and get smaller and smaller smaller you
get that spiral and today we're looking
at the angle here's how I gonna do it I
want you to imagine this is like a piece
of string okay so you could pick this
piece of string up you could hold it in
your hands now if we were to take this
piece of string and take the two ends
and have them meet together so that this
end and this end connected and formed a
circle okay so we're gonna go from this
down to this you see what I'm getting
here okay so you can draw a rough one on
your page there okay this ID here that a
over B what's it equal to what ratio is
it equal to to make it the golden ratio
it's another fraction very good
a plus B the whole thing right over a
the longer small section so in here what
have I got
I have be around here a so far so good
but now I wanna make an angle out of it
so put a point at the center of this
circle we've just made right there at
the center now the angle which and the
fancy word is subtended the angle which
is subtending here at the center by this
arc over here B this is the golden angle
in there that's the golden angle so the
question is like we know we know what
this is
this is fine what is it in third form
who remembers the fraction 1 plus root 5
on 2 and we've gotten rough decimal
approximation off one very good I'll put
a couple of extra decimal points minute
okay now here I'm gonna let you play it
for maybe three or four minutes okay
this is all you need to know actually
it's quite a few things right if this is
what you know this is and I've made this
out of this ratio can you find the size
of this angle in here in degrees can you
work it out you've got all the pieces
how'd it go now I could do a number of
things at this point I could just give
you the number that would be kind of the
equivalent of what Ryan is done I have
it but that doesn't yield any insight
right and it's like well why is that
true secondly I could just walk you
through a solution okay which I will in
a second but before I do that there's a
really important thing you need to do
right the person doing the work is the
person doing the learning there's that
makes it that makes sense doesn't it if
you're the one working through it and
this is why I gave you some time your
other one is actually going to gain some
insight or struggle with the hard part
problem and actually learn something new
okay so what am I going to be doing how
did I do is like I didn't have this told
to me I just knew the pieces and I
worked it out what have I done that you
haven't done okay
now when it comes to problem solving in
general and this is kind of like a
problem solving type question right I
think there are always two aspects to
every problem-solving question which you
can sort of file away in your general
purpose tools drawn right challenge
number one is you have a lot of
information you have a lot of
information and often what you have to
do is sift out what's important right
there are things in the question that
are distracting you from what you really
need okay now I have loads of things up
here okay I'm going to be bold and
suggest all I really need at least to
get started is these two okay now that's
I said just one of the parts of the
problem the other part like apart from
getting rid of what's not there is you
have to see what is there but isn't
obvious right so what am I done
put on because I'm after an angle got an
angle I've put some labels on these
angles I have X as the actual angle that
I want and I've got Y as that reflex
angle around the outside okay now it's a
circle I don't know very much about x
and y but I do know cos it's a circle
that if I put them together I ought to
get 360 degrees you agree with that now
not only do I see that but because these
go all the way around and these two go
all the way around right these ratios
should be the same right the ratio of
this length to this length should be the
same as the ratio from this angle to
this angle do you agree with that okay
angles legs they make up the same thing
so therefore let's move into actually
what I've got is x over okay with that
because I'm going along too short okay
now I'm gonna put this thing together I
want to solve this I wanna solve it I'm
solving for x so you can see what I've
got now is one equation two equations
don't forget finds a letter but it
really just stands for a number right so
I can work with it just fine when you've
got two equations and two numbers you
can solve this you've done simultaneous
equations to death right so we can do
this I'm gonna do some kind of
substitution right you know how the
other ways like elimination but that
tends to be when you have like an X plus
y and the next minus y and then you can
eliminate here it doesn't fit so neatly
so I'm gonna take this equation up here
I want to get rid of the Y's so I'm
gonna do this out of this slide I can
conclude this do you agree nothing too
dramatic there
but now that I know this I can pop it
directly in here 360 minus X on X right
equals five now I have gone from having
two equations and two unknowns now I
have one equation one unknown does that
make sense okay
I've said that Y is equal to this from
Equation one and I've just done a slight
rearrangement so I can substitute it out
here you happy with that okay now that's
kind of the critical step really right
what else can I do with this let's see
here I guess I would do this 360 on X
minus one equals five are you okay with
that
I broke a pot that fraction that's a
similar thing I did when I worked out
the golden ratio in the first place 360
on X is five plus one
I actually won X doughnut so I want X on
360 that's the reciprocal so this would
be the corresponding reciprocal and now
I just need this guy that's the greatest
cut away you're happy with that it
wasn't all that dramatic was it really
I've only used tools that you have at
your disposal what did I do that you
didn't do it really all started to begin
it's a bit like setting off some
dominoes right if you have if you can
work out what's the important
information and what's there but is only
implied and not you know sitting on the
surface for you to see it just sort of
leaps out at you okay now you know what
is so let's see here
okay have you caught up you there so
what I'm going to do is first I'm going
to give you a whole bunch of decimal
places and then I'm going to round them
off a little bit okay what I'm getting
as far as my calculator can tell me is a
hundred and thirty seven point five zero
seven seven six four one dot dot dot
okay you can kind of see why I've chosen
to go to the nearest one decimal place
that zero there's pretty close to just
being zero for the whole thing so I'm
going to call that one thirty seven
point five okay approximately one a
decimal place this is the golden angle